The jogan Experience people respond to
incentives when there's money companies
respond doctors respond everybody yeah I
mean I guess unfortunat I mean look it's
why we have this you know all these
great things in this country too but um
yeah I will I will give you so an
opthalmologist called me a few weeks ago
there's a drug and and the drug works
okay it's good it's good for people um
if you if something called wet macular
degeneration okay it's it's something
older people get and it can blind you so
there's a drug there's a couple drugs
that um that actually work for it they
they block the flow of um they block
blood vessel formation at the back of
the eye they help you so these are
administered opthalmologists administer
them in their offices so a drug like
that the opthalmologist actually buys
and charges Medicare or the private
insurer for okay what's happening and
and I saw this with a different drug
when I worked in the New York Times 15
years ago so nothing ever changes these
companies all play the same games is
that the companies that make this drug
are giving doctors a rebate on the
purchase price and and the more you use
the bigger the rebate and and this is a
drug that costs thousands of dollars per
uh per person per year okay it's dose
multiple times a year for a lot of these
people so what all this adds up to is if
you're an Opthomologist who's using a
lot of this the company is cutting you
in check for five or sometimes six
figures
sometimes multiple times a year okay
don't tell me that's not a bribe okay
because that's a bribe it may be legal
they may have found a way to do this and
he showed me he showed me the the the
check that his company or that his
Opthalmology practice had received and
it was huge okay and by the way these
doctors make a lot of money on their own
just doing the procedure they don't need
this but the but it's a way for the drug
company to get them to use this more
there's corruption all over our medical
system and how how does that get
resolved is there a way at this point or
is it the system itself is it just a
function of that's how human beings
behave when they have you know enough
regulation where they can get away with
some stuff and they just want to make
more and more money and it just becomes
that's what they're trying to do I mean
I don't know I mean just human beings I
mean if you're that opthalmologist in
Florida do you need another Ferrari but
maybe you don't think that way you don't
think that way you just think I can get
it right and I'm in this system and the
system is [__] already that's right
and and I'm using this drug because I
know it works and it's good for patients
the problem is you're then you're then
having incentives to ignore the problem
if there is one later and so in this
case the guy actually said to me he's
like this is is a good drug it does work
he said but sometimes if we dose it too
many times we can get there can be sort
of a paradoxical effect where it stops
working if you're one of those doctors
who's on the tit and getting that check
every quarter or every six months or you
know however frequently you get it
you're going to it's going to be harder
for you to see the problem because all
of the sudden you have a financial
incentive not to see it
right I don't I don't know what we do
about any of
this
except talk about it and make sure
people know talk about it make sure
people know and you know you need
Senators that call this stuff out and we
need you know you need people that run
these companies to be it just have to
have ethical boundaries you know because
they make great stuff the thing about
pharmaceutical drug companies is like I
would never say we don't need them
that's crazy how many people they've
helped you know how many drugs the
pharmaceutical companies that we we
currently demonize because of of this
thing this this for-profit aspect of it
but how many of them have brought drugs
to the market that have fixed all sorts
of problems that people have been
suffering for forever yes yeah they just
they just can't go ham just can't you
can't go crazy and force people to take
your stuff like that's a bad
relationship a good relationship is a
consumer and a provider and the provider
develops these drugs that are very
beneficial to people and most of them
are a lot of them are right some of some
of them are but we they they do have
drugs that they've developed that are
really beneficial for people they really
do they're real and we can't [__]
throw out the baby with the bath water I
just think that it just H the problem is
also the process right because to bring
a drug to Market costs so much [__]
money it costs a crazy it's so
prohibitive for most if if you were like
some pharmacologist or some biologist
and you you guys were working together
and you developed something you had this
idea about a pathway and you figured out
something and maybe this could fix it
and you really figured it out sure good
[__] luck right good luck getting
that thing approved well what I mean one
of the great disappointments for me in
the last 10 years is realizing that if
you had to choose between a sewer system
and a medical system You' choose a sewer
system like in other words in other
words what's more efficient what what
actually helps human health more the
great gains for human longevity in the
last 200 years have been really simple
things clean water try to get the air
clean don't bury you know don't have
like meat packing plants in the middle
of the Cities don't B don't have giant
graveyards in the middle of cities like
that stuff have you seen or excuse me
have you read dissolving Illusions I
have not it's a fantastic book about
just that huh and the beginning of it is
they talk about the conditions that
people lived in CU you never really
think about it like what would be like
to live in a city before there were cars
well guess what but nothing gets to you
that's right you're not getting fresh
vegetables in the winter you're not
getting vitamins right there's massive
malnutrition starvation extreme poverty
people living in squalor terrible
sanitation I mean open out houses for
entire blocks of people yep and just
crazy diseases yep and they all lived on
top of each other and again malnutrition
vitamin D no sunlight exposure in the
winter etc etc and a lot of those people
got horrible diseases because of that
just like they did in the olden times
like we know about when people dump [__]
in the streets and the pl game the like
the like 18 the first you know the first
few Decades of the Industrial Revolution
were terrible for human health like
people got you know they got crammed
together they got sicker and then about
1850 they started to figure this stuff
out for a hundred years like we did
great okay but it wasn't really medicine
it was really more basic than that and
so the last 50 67 years we've spent more
and more and more money on medicine
trying to like ex continue that growth
in life expectancy and it turns out like
there there are limits to it they're
just limits and we seem to be reaching
them and the and the problem is in the
US anyway we're now spending so much
money and having so many unnecessary
medical procedures of marginal value I'm
not even talking about the I'm talking
about like value to people that we've we
seem to have topped
out